foreign
Huntsville Texas what's up Zach
not much just uh trying to get out of
this ice storm yeah welcome to it man
welcome to welcome to Texas welcome to
Texas
it's cold once a year when it is ice
falls from the sky
I know right so what's up dude
uh nothing good unfortunately oh man
tell me about it
okay
um uh the question is basically we need
to know what boundaries or how to set
boundaries or whatever the case may be
with a friend who is in an abusive
relationship
Define abuse for me
um I'll give you examples if you need to
but uh
to cover it all he's
he's verbally abusive he is neglectful
of her and their infant child
I got one daughter that's living with
his grandparents because he's too big of
a to stand up to his grandmother and
tell her no the kid's going to come stay
home with me even though there's no
custody Arrangement whatsoever
we have have to constantly help her out
because he won't like um like I'll give
this one example
um a week after their infant daughter
was born she calls me and asked me to
take her to her one week checkup and her
quote was he doesn't want to
they recently they spent a week uh her
and her daughter spent a week in the
hospital they checked her the baby in
for observations because she had gone to
the ER because the baby hasn't gained
much weight
and he didn't show up for a single day
that they were in the hospital we took
her there and we took her home
and we're at the point where like I
I value marriage about as much as you
and Dave do but we're at the point we're
no longer supporting them being together
we're telling her if you call us with
any problems we're going to tell you to
just to leave him because we're getting
sick of it
she seems to somewhat be on board with
the idea of leaving him but she is
terrified of the idea of going to a
shelter which is the last thing I told
her she needed to do
and
at this point I'm getting it at this
point we're trying to figure out how to
protect our family and set boundaries
and stuff up so that
we don't have to keep being stressed out
by the constant neglect and abuse that
is coming with this but at the same time
we don't want to abandon her because we
know that that's just gonna leave her no
choice but to stay there because my me
and my roommates were literally all
she's got
what I'm going to tell you is hard okay
because you got a great heart and I wish
there were more people who cared about
hurting people in the world
but at the end of the day
you can't make her do anything
you can call and I would recommend you
call the authorities because
[Music]
um
uh for because if the kids are being
abused to be neglected if they're being
left alone
but at the end of the day the fact that
she hasn't
called 9-1-1 screaming
bloody murder that some old woman has
taken her baby that's her choice blame a
husband all you want
the fact that she doesn't want to live
in a shelter totally get that that she
hasn't come to you and said I need a
place to stay for 60 or 90 days will you
help me she hasn't done that
and so one of the most difficult
challenging things is being in a
relationship with other adults
because we can't make them do the things
that we can just so clearly see
would help them be safe and whole you
throw kids in the mix and it's it's even
worse
what is uh do you know this guy would
have stopped you from calling this guy
he
um I'm not 100 confident in my ability
to defend myself and he can get pretty
violent for example like another reason
why I can't stand this I
I got up four in the morning I did my
delivery I was going home I went to
Walmart because we were preparing for
Halloween or something of some or other
and then
I get a call asking to take her to the
ER because she's got a prolapsed uterus
I go over there
that he initially called me because he
didn't think his car would make the 30
mile trip South down to the ER
I go over there and he's sitting in his
car screwing with it I go inside she's
getting the baby and all the stuff ready
for it and I swear to God I've never
been closer to punching him in my life I
got them and everybody ready to go he
sat down and ate pizza
and I
why have you made this this your War
I like you wake up every day enraged and
you go to bed every day enraged and you
spin out and you spin out and you spin
out and she hasn't asked for your help
or when she does she just wants a ride
and you give her that ride and you give
her advice you say I think you should
leave and she goes I know and then she
doesn't
at some point you're continuing to
torture yourself because this guy is a
terrible human being and make no mistake
he sounds like a terrible human being
an absolute terrible human being
on all counts
but your daily choice to just Swan Dive
into that cesspool
is you choosing to make your life
shorter you're going to have a stroke
and you're gonna have a heart he doesn't
think about you every day you think
about him a lot
yep it's mostly because like I'll have a
pretty good day and then she'll text me
and be like hey I need this or this or
this because
I'm not getting it
and I I will admit I'm very close to
just calling it I'm what's torturing me
is I don't know how to tell her we can't
participate in this any longer without
getting her making her think that when
she finally gets sick of it we're not
going to be there to help I want to make
sure exactly like you just said it
you take her out for coffee you and a
couple other guys that way she doesn't
believe this is some sort of romantic
move on your part
and you'd be surprised at how signals
get crossed when people are in these
kind of situations
and you tell her very clearly we cannot
be your fallback plan
24 hours a day 365 days a year
we love you and we are scared to death
for you and we're scared of those kids
but you're an adult and you're making
adult choices
the moment you're ready to leave our
front door is open for you
but until then you're gonna have to make
some grown-up choices
if this is the life you are choosing
this is the mayor and I and let me let
me be honest
okay it makes me sick to my stomach to
say that because I don't think she's
consciously choosing this I think she's
absolutely feels stuck and trapped this
may have been the world she grew up with
who knows they may be threatened to keep
her baby to make up all kinds of stuff
she may have an addiction that you know
nothing about who like there's a million
different variables here
I've seen it all and then I know I
haven't seen any of it okay
you can't control any of those things
you can only control you
and so I think you are very very honest
and clear about your boundaries
um
I do want to ask one thing just because
this is the only really this is the
biggest worry about if it comes to the
point where we're her only option we
take her in our house would it be wrong
for me to or is there a better way to
say we're not taking you in unless
you're leaving him
I mean you could say whatever you want
no I I I know that the only reason I
haven't said that yet is because I don't
know if that's the right thing to help
her or if it's
I I mean it would be foolish of me to
weigh in on that because I don't know
like you you get to put the boundaries
and stipulations it's like when somebody
donates five thousand dollars and say
you have to spin it like this this and
this I may say that's ridiculous it
doesn't matter what I think it's their
money
I can either choose to take it or not
take it
and the moment she moved she says I'm
come get me I need to get out of here
he's at work you
um she needs to call and have a
restraining order put on
so he didn't show up at your front door
and by choosing to get involved you're
choosing to
potentially Put Yourself In Harm's Way
it's not by your hand but in your lap
you didn't ask for this it came to you
and you're the kind of guy that steps in
the middle in the gap
and so I'll tell you to be wise and
don't be a hero and this isn't a movie
set
so call the local authorities and make
sure she's got the resources that she
needs Beyond you can give her a place to
stay
that's safe for her and her kids you
cannot do trauma therapy
and you cannot do job placement service
like she's gonna need some professional
help significant professional help
you're not an attorney that's going to
help her get full custody of her kids
but it's telling to me
that Grandma took the baby
and she hasn't burned people's house
down if somebody takes my daughter I
don't care who they are
it's going to be a bad bad day and I'm a
pretty chill guy
and Kevin help what my wife would do
see what I'm saying like there's a
there's a clearly another side to this
what I will promise you is if you walk
around bathing in Rage you're not going
to make wise choices
if you wake up every day with a single
fixation on this guy it's saving this
woman and
finally coming up with the right thing
so that she may
you're gonna end up getting yourself
hurt
and so I think what you and your
roommates need to do is come up with
some sort of
guys let's all sit down let's spend half
an hour on this and let's ride out on a
piece of paper all gonna agree here's
the here's our boundaries on this deal
and then all three of y'all all four of
you how many roommates you got y'all all
go out to IHOP and you take her with you
go to Waffle House take her with you and
you say hey worried about you you know
that
we love helping you we love loving you
but we can't participate in this any
longer
the moment you're ready to leave we'll
come get you
and if you want to say but it's got to
be for good fine I think the last number
I read was people go back six or seven
times I think five or six or seven times
I go back to abusive relationships
um
so may not last long but such it is you
can put whatever stipulations you want
the last thing she needs is some other
person to come in and take her life from
her
she needs to be given a context of
Safety and Security so she can make the
hard choices on her own
thank you for stepping up man thank you
for stepping up
but knowing
what you can control versus what you
can't control that's one of the
cornerstones
of a healthy life
and unfortunately we all control very
very little
but we do control our ability to love so
thank you for stepping in the gap let me
know how it goes man